je t'offre l'opportunité de devenir un
kingman
genre à l'espion en quelque sorte
depuis 1849 les tailleurs klinsmann pour
habiller les personnages les plus
influents de la planète en 1919 beaucoup
parmi eux avec un désir de maintenir la
paix et de protéger
le fondateur comprirent qu'ils pouvaient
utiliser cette richesse et cette
influence pour le bien de tous c'est
ainsi que commence à notre agence
internationale et indépendante de
renseignement opérant un très grand
niveau de discrétion
lagence kezman
[Musique]
bienvenue au club
c'est assez manière qu'on juge
non
il n'y est jamais
m
magnier
maxime fantastique au vélo l'heure est
venue de verser de l'huile sur le feu
harnais est prêt
on va voir ça
il y est revenue
pourquoi les hommes sont ils toujours un
travail de seebach
[Musique]
il va vous falloir un costume sur